on a toujours l'impression que la rumeur
ne fait de victimes que parmi les gens
peu éduqués est ce que c'est le cas a
surtout pas non surtout pas il ya des
études savantes qui montrent que la
croyance dans les extraterrestres et les
plus belles et plus prégnante elle plus
importante chez les gens qui ont des
diplômes universitaires que chez les
autres
donc non ça veut pas dire ça ça veut
dire en revanche que nous avons un
regard sur la rumeur qui est un regard
extrêmement comment dire en surplomb
condescendant nous pensons que la rumeur
d'abord sa touche toujours les autres on
va jamais dire c'est moi qui vais je
vais vous raconter une bonne rumeur donc
ça ça va pas on s'est toujours un
diagnostic a posteriori qu'on va faire
sur des populations qu'on estime -
estimable précisément alors ça peut être
dans en termes de classes sociales les
roumains c'est souvent chez les
prolétaires chez les employés se passe
chez les cadres mais tout ça c'est des
choses qu'on ne vérifie pas
expérimentalement c'est quand on vérifie
comment circule l'information ou la
rumeur ne circule pas de cette manière
là il ya d'autres circuits mais bête
mais en tout cas pas il n'y a pas d'un
côté elle choisit pas que les femmes ou
que les prolétaires scène ça n'existe
pas
[Musique]